Speaker 1: Well, my friends, they did it,
this shouldn't even be notable.
This shouldn't be newsworthy.
This shouldn't be a story.
But 35 Republicans joined Democrats in the
House of Representatives to vote to pass a
bill that would set up this bipartisan 9/11
style commission to investigate the Donald
Trump, January 6th, insurrection riot.
And it is incredible that it is only 35 members
from the Republican Party that joined one
hundred and seventy six Republicans or what?
No.
One seventy five, one seven one seventy five,
one hundred and seventy five Republicans.
The vote was 252 to 175, saying we don't want
to know what happened and we don't want all
of these remaining questions answered in terms
of the motivations and the genesis and the
explanation of why did it take so long to
get a bolstad police presence and the military,
all of these different things that should
be investigated.
They don't want to know or they believe that
it would point back to them in some way.
This is the greatest motivation for these
Republicans not wanting this investigation,
which is that many of them know that it would
not look good for them.
But we will get back to that Axios reporting.
As I told you yesterday, House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy opposed this commission and
it looked like there would be between 20 and
50 Republicans who would vote in favor of
it and 35 did.
This makes it more difficult for Senate Minority
Leader Mitch McConnell to just dismiss it
all as partizan, because you did have 35 Republicans
in the House who were in favor of it.
Now, as I told you yesterday, the setup is
really as bipartisan as you can get.
Democrats control the House.
Yes.
So there is going to be some more control
that Democrats have rather than Republicans
over the commission.
But it would be a 10 member commission, five
members selected by Democrats, five members
selected by Republicans.
The chair would be a Democrat because Democrats
control the House and the vice chair would
be a Republican.
And if they are going to issue subpoenas,
which presumably they would, every subpoena
has to be signed off on by the chair and the
vice chair.
So there are Republicans.
I mean, listen, if I'm Kevin McCarthy and
I realize that I was on the phone with Trump
on the day of the insurrection, and the content
of that conversation may be of interest to
the committee and I might be subpoenaed.
That is going to be something that would require
both the Democratic chair and the Republican
vice chair.
And indeed, there seems to be at least somewhat
of an appetite from Republicans to figure
out what happened.
And so if you're Kevin McCarthy and you're
thinking I might have to testify here, or
at least documents related to my conversation
with Trump might be part of this, it makes
sense.
You would try to make this go away.
So the next step here, now that the House
has passed it, the Senate majority leader,
Chuck Schumer, Democrat from New York, has
said the bill will get a vote.
It's not clear whether any Republicans in
the Senate are going to get on board.
Two days ago, Mitch McConnell said he can't
support it in its then current form.
Two sources say that it's conceivable that
Mitch McConnell will have to change his tune
because of these 35 Republicans who voted
in favor of it, 10 Republican senators would
be necessary for this to pass.
You cannot pass this in the Senate with 50
plus Kamala Harris as the tie breaking vote.
That would be the budget reconciliation process.
It cannot be used here.
So in order for this commission to happen,
for it to be voted through in the Senate,
you will need all 50 Democrats and 10 Republicans
or 49 Democrats and 11 Republicans.
Or you can do the math.
Any combination that gets you to 60.
This could have started months ago.
There was no interest before Joe Biden was
president.
There was not even the possibility before
Joe Biden was president because Democrats
didn't didn't control the Senate.
And now hopefully we are getting closer to
that.
It could have been done a long time ago.
It really could.
And it's because of Republicans and Republicans
only that it has not yet happened.
So we're going to follow it.
And there are any number of different reasons
why different Republicans would want this
not to take place.
But I would say I am more confident than I've
been in the last two weeks today that ultimately
this is going to happen.
And let's now look at some of the I don't
even really want to call them reasons because
they barely even have anything to do with
the actual commission and the riots.
But let's look at some of the words that came
out of the mouths of Republicans during yesterday's
debate about this on the floor
of the House.